the clark county school district will be
focusing on chronic student absences
among other things at tonight's school
board meeting that's right so the
district is trying to figure out why
there is this chronic student
absenteeism distance learning certainly
plays a role in that from the pandemic
hector mejia looking live at those
numbers this morning and again they'll
talk about it today trustees will this
report hector good morning
good morning and that report says it
will take ongoing comprehensive
initiatives to reduce what they're
seeing right now so it won't be an easy
fix and here's what we're learning from
that report it says nearly 4 out of 10
students miss school regularly at the
clark county school district it shows
chronic absenteeism in the district is
37 percent for this current school year
the rate went up from last year and
almost doubled what was reported before
the pandemic we discovered ccsd's rate
is significantly higher when ranked
against other school districts for the
2020 2021 school year
denver public schools la and san diego
unified school districts actually had
lower absenteeism rates than ccsd did
during that same period and this is just
one of many topics being discussed at
the agenda tonight the regular board
meeting starts at 5 p.m inside the greer
education building this one right here
at flamingo and mcleod reporting live
hector mejia live local now